So let's now dig in more specifically to just
one of the pardons and clemency grants that
Donald Trump did yesterday. So I already kind
of given you the big picture, 11 people received
different forms of clemency from Donald Trump
yesterday.
The, the theme is it's elites pardoning elites.
It's Trump setting up a framework of pardoning
both Republicans and Democrats in advance
of pardoning his cronies. It is the normalization
of corruption, political corruption as that
even really a crime Trump insisting on Twitter.
Nobody even really knows what Roger Stone
did, which is of course not true, but it's
part of this idea that political corruption
and cronyism and all this stuff Trump said
he would eliminate as president, it actually
is stuff he's not only not eliminating, he
thinks should simply be legal. Now when it
comes to the specific idea of pardoning former
Illinois governor rod Blagojevich, Donald
Trump admits he doesn't really know blog boy
of itch, but he did see rod Blagojevich, his
wife on TV, and that is what gave him information
about the [inaudible] case. Take a look at
what Donald Trump said yesterday about that.
We have commuted the sentence of rod Vic.
He served
eight years in jail a long time. And uh, I
watched his wife on television. I don't know
him very well. I bet him a couple of times
he was on for a short while of the apprentice
years ago. Seemed like a very nice person,
don't know him, but he served eight years
in jail. There's a long time to go. Many people
disagree with the sentence. He's a Democrat,
he's not a Republican.
So notice that he says, I don't know, blue
boy of itch, but I saw his wife on television.
So I started looking around. What is it that
rod Blagojevich, his wife has said and done
on television that might interest Donald Trump?
Well, it turns out that Patty Blagojevich
has been on Fox news a few times and she specifically
linked rod Blagojevich his situation to Donald
Trump's saying James comi and Robert Mueller
have perverted the law against Donald Trump.
Just like they perverted the law against my
husband, rod Blagojevich the following month
in another Fox news appearance, Patty Blagojevich
said the same people who went after her husband
are going after Donald Trump now defending
Donald Trump against investigations saying
this very popular Republican talking point.
They meaning investigators, Democrats who
knows, are trying to undo elections and play
politics instead of doing what they're supposed
to do. Uh, supportive of Donald Trump during
these appearances. Check out this clip
or have you heard any more about the potential
for a pardon from the president? Um, I haven't
heard anything at all. I, you know, we are
so grateful for the present to even be thinking
about us in that respect. He's given our family,
um, a tremendous amount of hope and, you know,
we're confident that the president is going
to do what he thinks is right regarding that.
Um, so I mean, we are, um, you know, we say
our prayers every night and hopefully look
for the to the day that my husband gets home
or, you know, this whole thing that this happened
in this weekend is just so familiar to me.
Um, you know, I can't believe these people
are added again, um, you know, they use, whether
it's using false information to obtain, you
know, warrants or turning, you know, trusted
advisors and despise against you, against
you. It's, um, it's like almost like I'm reliving
it all over again. When you talk about this
weekend, you're talking about Paul Manafort.
Um, I'm talking, no, no, I'm talking about
like this, the latest road revelations about
how, um, the Pfizer court and how that they
used a slander was essentially opposition
research, slander against the president to,
you know, to spy on him. So
it makes no sense, Patti bla Goya is, they're
trying to use some of the debunked Trump talking
points about the Russia probe using them.
Inarticulately but the idea is clear, defend
Trump while saying we have suffered at the
same hands and this worked very, very well.
Trump acknowledges he saw Patty Blagojevich
on TV and now he's pardoning rod Blagojevich.
If you want pardons or commuted sentences,
you know what to do, bad mouth comi and Mueller
while defending Donald Trump and Trump will
do anything you want. And in the meantime,
we've also learned that the construction company
owner that Donald Trump pardoned, a guy named
Paul Pogue, his son and daughter in law donated
$200,000 to Donald Trump's campaign since
August of last year. Once again, it's more
of the same. Trump said he would get corruption
out. Trump has actually done more to normalize
corruption than any recent president. And
uh, to, uh, think about it another way.
If you want to zoom out and look at what's
going on here, this is another one of the
ways in which Mitch McConnell and other Republican
senators are enabling all of this. They ignored
and actually blocked relevant testimony and
evidence from the impeachment trial, which
they knew they were going to be voting for
an acquittal for Trump at the end of, from
the beginning. They are now looking the other
way as Donald Trump is laying the groundwork
to normalize corruption, to start pardoning
his associates. And this is very similar to
something, there's elements of this that are
similar about how Saddam Hussein came to power
in Iraq. You know, we often wonder here in
the United States, how does a country just
lose control and go from being a relatively
secular and advanced country developed country
like Iraq into being taken over by someone
like Saddam Hussein? How does it happen? It
could never happen here.
Well it's been described actually how Saddam
came to power in Iraq and it was an Iraq that
was previously quite modern, quite moderate
in many ways. And you create what is sometimes
called a Republic of fear. This is actually
described in a book by Canon Makia Kanaan
Makia later lobbied for the U S to invade
Iraq and has not been right on anything but
very interestingly describing sort of the
atmosphere in Iraq, in the lead up to Saddam
Hussein taking over. And the idea is this
Republic of fear, you pardon some people and
then you essentially own them. You get away
with, um, uh, manipulating the justice system
and courts, and you create a situation where
people who you appear to be on the same side
as fear you because they worry you might turn
on them. People who are on opposite sides
fear you because they see that you are running
rampant and flouting all of the norms and
checks and balances and, and all of the infrastructure
that is supposed to prevent exactly this type
of despotic behavior.
And then all of a sudden you get a situation
where you might take someone that you previously
were praising and you very publicly point
to them as an example of what's wrong. You
put them in front of the public and say, this
person did all of these bad things. And then
everybody who you've been protecting all of
a sudden starts to panic. Trump was protecting
me before, but is this the end? I better start
turning on the people around me. I better
pledge my loyalty to Trump, uh, louder than
anybody else and I'll do whatever he wants
because I've got to stay on Donald Trump's
good side. This sort of dynamic. Uh, very
similar to what was going on in the increasingly
corrupt Iraq that was ultimately under the
power of Saddam Hussein. Doesn't mean everything
is the same about the U S in 20, 20 and Iraq
decades ago. But an interesting crossover
there, and this is all Trump normalizing the
exact type of corruption
that he said so many times he was going to
be the guy to get rid of. Let me know what
you think about the pardon is we will take
a quick break and be back out for
this with much, much more